hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem
word break so we're given an input
string
and a dictionary of strings called word
dict and we want to return true
if and only if s can be broken
up into separate strings such that every
separate string in s is also
found inside of our word dict and we
are allowed to use words from the word
dict multiple times
so for example let's say we're given an
input string leak code
and we're given a word dictionary of
words called
leat and code so obviously in this case
we could split this string right into
separate strings lee
right break it down in this middle
position and then the sep
the second string would be code right so
clearly this can be broken up into words
that are found in the word dictionary so
therefore we are going to return true
now what if we took code outside of our
word dictionary
well then in that case this portion is a
word right but we have no matching word
in our dictionary for the remainder code
so in that case we would have to return
false and you know let's say we had an
input string instead
called lea and li again right so two
leads in a row would
would we return true yes because we're
allowed to use this word from our
dictionary multiple times right clearly
it matches this
and it also matches the first portion
now let's start off with the brute force
approach
how would we even structure a brute
force solution well there's actually
two ways to do it but one of them
happens to be more efficient and i'll
tell you why
so one thing we could try for an input
string like this one we could check okay
the first character
right basically the first prefix of the
string l
by itself right is this a word that's
found in our word dictionary it's not
right
so let's try maybe the first two
characters together are a word right
that's not it either
we would try the first three right
basically we would try every single
portion from the beginning until we
found a
matching word that does exist in our
word dictionary
and we know that we are gonna find one
like this right the first
four characters of the string are
a word right so once we found that what
are we gonna do
clearly we have a sub problem right we
found a matching word for this portion
but now we want to know can we break up
the rest of this string
with words from our dictionary so that's
kind of how uh we're going to
do it right that's what's going to be
the sub problem basically so instead of
starting from the first position in the
string we would start
at this position in the string and try
to word break it
now in this approach what we're going to
basically be doing potentially is from
every single starting position right
we're going to check every prefix right
so
from the first starting position we
might also get if you know this happened
to be a word then we would
start at this position and then do the
same thing for this right every
word starting here so basically we're
going to try every word how many
different words are we going to end up
trying we're going to try
let's say n is the size of our string n
and we're going to try basically from
every single starting position to the
end
so that's going to basically be n times
n now
we could also do it a different way
instead of trying
every single possible you know prefix
let's
just check every word in our word
dictionary and see if that matches
for example this first word is four
characters
long right so what we're going to do is
we're going to check the first
four characters in our string does this
match this word clearly it does right
so what does that tell us that tells us
now you know we have the same sub
problem as before
we're going to start from these this
next position now right and check
and from here we're basically going to
be doing the same thing right so we're
going to check
is elite basically you know the first
four characters does that match lee
this does not match lee right so now
let's check the next word in our word
dictionary and check does that match
uh the characters over here it does
right we found
code so this is basically another way to
do this problem instead of checking
every single possible prefix right of
any length what we're going to be doing
is we're going to be checking every
single word in our word
dictionary as the prefix so instead of
being
o of n times n we're going to be doing o
of n
because potentially we are going to be
going through every single starting
position but we're going to be
multiplying
by the number of words in our word
dictionary which is let's call it
m and the reason why we're going to be
doing this approach
is because it's going to be a little bit
more efficient and the reason is they
they tell us below in the problem
statement that the max size of word
dictionary
is going to be smaller than the max size
of the string so this is overall
probably going to be more efficient
now this isn't going to be the overall
time complexity we are actually going to
multiply it by another
n because when we're checking for
example you know this brief
this string when we're checking does
that match the first four characters
here
that's also a end time operation because
it could you know potentially be the
size of the input string s
so this is basically going to be the
overall time complexity n squared
multiplied by m so i'm just going to
basically show you the same formula that
i usually do i'm going to give you a
quick illustration of what the decision
tree would look like then we're going to
understand how we could
cache that to eliminate repeated work
and then by understanding that we're
going to go to the optimal
dynamic programming solution the bottom
up approach and then we're going to code
that up usually the dp solution
is a lot less code than caching so we're
going to be looking at our input string
neat code
so i think that's a little bit better
than neat code wouldn't you say so
what the decision tree is gonna be is
we're gonna start at the first position
right for example i
equals zero we're gonna be keeping track
of whatever index we're at right because
we know that if we can find a word
you know that matches neat for example
then the sub problem is gonna be
you know finding words that can match
the remainder of the string for example
if we did that
our i instead of starting at index zero
would basically be starting at
index four right so that's kind of what
this that's what the sub problem is
going to be
so really we're only going to have one
variable that we're keeping track of
in this backtracking solution and so
remember we mentioned
we're not going to be doing it like this
we're not going to check every single
prefix
we're going to have decisions in our
decision tree based on the number of
words that are in the word dictionary so
we're going to have a decision for neat
we're going to have a decision for elite
and we're going to have a decision for
code now what we're going to notice is
when we try elite on here
right basically is four characters
therefore we're going to check the first
four characters of here
compare it does that match lee it does
not right we're just one character off
that first one so basically that means
we're not going to continue down this
path now let's try code does code match
the first four characters definitely not
so we're not even gonna
continue down this path either of course
neat
does match this so we are gonna continue
down here
we're gonna do three more decisions
basically one for
every single word in our word dictionary
now one thing though
is when we are starting here we know we
match the first four characters so by
this point we are now going to be
at i equals four meaning we're going to
be looking at this
part of the string so as we can see
checking neat that's four characters
long so let's check
four characters starting from here
that's not matching of course so then
we're not going to continue here lee
does that match over here nope we're not
continue down this path
code does code match this portion yes it
exactly matches
so therefore we are going to update our
i pointer again since we matched four
more characters
we're just gonna take i and add four to
it now
so now i is going to be at eight
and eight happens to be that exact
position
right after the end of the string right
this is where index
8 is therefore we basically know that we
were able to
match the entire string therefore we
know we can return true right once we
find a single true
that means we just terminate we end the
function we can just call
we can just return true and the function
is done now from this example it might
not be super intuitive why we would use
a cache but let's say we had another
path in our decision tree that led us to
for example
index i equals five right and let's say
we had we used all three decisions
in that path and let's say none of them
yielded
the correct result meaning we were not
able to word break this string
from starting at index five so then we
would return false from this
path right and we would want to cache
that we would want to say
that let's say dp of index five right we
would want to set that to
false basically what we're saying is if
we ever
reached this same function call if we
ever tried it again maybe you know this
decision tree could be really big maybe
there would be another path
from you know somewhere over here where
we tried index i equals 5 again
in that case we would want to return
false immediately because we saw
from here there was no possible way to
break it down therefore we don't need to
redo
all of that work if we you know try the
same exact thing
so we discovered that our base case is
going to be dp
of 8 because a is the length of the
string basically is going to be
true right if we can ever get to that
last index we're going to return true
so what we're going to do is now do the
bottom up approach right we're going to
go through every single
index in reverse order right so we would
start at the last character which is
position
seven right and see can we word break
the remainder
of this string you know and we would try
every single word right like neat does
neat match this string well they're not
even the same size right if we tried to
match
neat on four characters starting from
here we would go
out of bounds of this string right
there's not enough character so of
course this is going to be
false right it wouldn't match neat it
wouldn't match the other two
words in our dictionary either and
that's obviously going to be true for dp
of 6
dp of 5 as well so both of these are
also going to be
false right basically if we started from
6 or if we started from 5
we would not be able to match any of the
words in our dictionary
but now if we start here index 4 so
we're now trying to figure out dp of 4
is that true
well yes it is right it doesn't match
neat it doesn't match elite but it does
match
code so we are going to set dp of 4
equal to true
so now let's keep doing it until we get
to the first character so now we're
going to be trying from dp
of 3 right so starting from this
character are we going to be able to
match any of these well none of these
words even start with a t
so of course we're not going to be able
to match so dp of 3 is going to be false
what's dp of 2 gonna be it's also going
to be false because
if we were to start at this character
this e
would we be able to match any of the
words in our word dictionary of course
we would not and
what about this position if we started
here would we be able to match any of
the words
in our word dictionary again not so dpf3
dpf2
and dp of 1 are going to be false
meaning we cannot word break this string
if we start at any of these first any of
these three positions basically
now we're finally at the result that we
were looking for dp
of zero is dp of zero gonna be true
well let's take a look so we're starting
at
the first character in the string can we
match any of the strings we can't match
lead we can't match code but
neat it does match this portion of the
string
starting at index zero so then the
question becomes
we're asking can we break the entire
string starting at
index zero so now since we did match the
first
four characters we want to know were we
able to match the remainder of the
string right so we want to know
starting from here were we able to match
this string to words in our word
dictionary now this is why we computed
this bottom up right because
this is index 4 right notice how we
already computed
index 4 over here right it's the one
that's highlighted in green
because it was true we were able to do
it so
basically the equation that we would use
for this is going to be
dp of 0 plus
the length of the word that we were able
to match with
and we know the length of the word
length of the word
neat is going to be 4 so basically we
can replace this length of the word with
four so zero plus four is just dp of
four we know that was true
so we can set dp of zero equal to true
so this is basically uh the result right
this is how we're going to compute
it and this is what we're going to
assign dp of 0 to and once we've done
that we've computed the result
we know we can return true for the
overall function
so with that being said let's jump into
the code so our cache is going to be
let's say a one-dimensional array right
because for every position i
in the string s we are going to have a
value so we're going to initialize this
to false it's going to be the length of
the string s
plus 1 for our base case and we are
going to initialize our base case we
know that it's the last position
basically the position
the position out of bounds of the string
so the length of
s and we know that's going to be set to
true that's our base case
so now we're going to go through every
position i in
the length of the string starting at the
last index and working our way to the
beginning so that's why i'm using the
decrementer of negative one
and we're going to go up until the
beginning of the string
and for each position i we want to try
every single word in our word dictionary
and see if the word
matches this portion so first we have to
see if
starting at position i the string s even
has enough
characters for w to be compared to it so
what we're going to do is we're going to
check
i plus the length of w and we want to
know is it less than or
equal to the length of s if that's the
case
then that means there are enough
characters in
s for us to compare them so that's what
exactly what we're going to do we're
going
if this is true then let's compare so we
want to know if that's true
and if s starting at index i
going up until i plus the length
of w so basically let's say
w was three characters then we want to
know the first three characters in
s starting at index i are they exactly
equal
if they are equal then we wanna know
okay so dp of
i is going to be set to dp
of i plus the length of w right that was
the relationship we got
i plus the length of whatever the word
happens to be
now if we got a single a way to word
break this
starting at index i that means we can
basically stop this loop right we don't
have to look at every single word in the
dictionary if we found at least
one way we were able to word break it
then we're gonna stop so basically if dp
of i
is true then we can break out of this
for loop and then move on to the next
index so we're going to start basically
at the last index
keep going until we've gotten to index 0
and then once we've done that we know we
can actually return that
and that's going to be stored in dp of
zero so believe it or not
that is the entire code about 10 lines i
think and
this is a pretty efficient solution as
you can see so i hope that this was
helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching